hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pop goes now we're
on the fifth night and it shouldn't be
too bad and it's got to be bad and I'm
gonna dial on everything's gonna be
horrible and you can shut the F up oh
god weasel is going I didn't even think
about it
alright forgot that we're going right
away shut up shut up I got stuff to do
and I've got things to worry about it's
not you that might be the party or no
this birthday room were you going buddy
boo there's something else here that I
need to worry about besides just these
people because I only died only died cuz
they stole my phone cuz they didn't give
an umma number heat in their lives and
they need a little more in the vents if
I'm gonna be able to do that why are you
not going anywhere why are you not going
anyways no one going anywhere why is no
one go okay there we go
we're to go to oh ah
that's the party room okay that makes
more sense okay alright I got it
not too bad not too bad not too bad I
know he's going back in that same room
that he just went in sorry sorry sorry
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry I caught
you peeping I didn't mean to cut you
people like that birthday room how
quaint after all I know where you go are
you ladies oh hello I didn't mean to ask
if you were ladies a man if you were
still there okay got that easy-peasy
oh [ __ ] I lost I sure did I get it I
don't know if I got that oh I think I
got it okay wow wow I'm great
well I'm amazing this came Wow I'm
really cool Wow really awesome you know
yeah pretty cool what I managed to do
with a little bit of panic and a lot of
elbow grease a lot of spit flying in my
screen a lot of unnecessary I've [ __ ]
it
I [ __ ] it real hard there oh I was
bragging about how great I was and I got
caught in the ass like that no no that's
that's not what I meant I didn't I
didn't get caught him yeah I I bragged
and bragging is high bragging is
bad don't brag oh oh I don't know what
that is
that's new what do I do about the ocean
dad or night Oh something changed I
don't like that I don't like that I know
he went in there you don't need to tell
me you went in there who the Frick was
that and why I do what you don't you
don't need that phone why I shut down
that room Aisha oh come on I shut down
the room well that's hardly fair this
seems a little bit precocious I don't
know if precocious is the right word to
use about it but hello oh hello hey it's
a whole party here why did the ladies go
where did the ladies go [ __ ] Oh Frick a
dick oh you're there okay that seems far
are you sure you want to travel that far
for the birthday room for the big
birthday boy with this pumpkin big
birthday presents get Punk'd bingo Bongo
okay give me I don't know if it's gonna
happen with them
little little little the tiny itty bitty
you know the horrible horrified hi sorry
the horrible horrifying skeleton that I
saw of some endoskeleton Frick oh my god
where is he oh no a fraction of a second
to loot oh and they're gone - I'm full
burn oh oh okay well but I'm still full
bore nope today he doesn't have all the
parts he's got some of the parts but not
all the parts which gives me some time a
lot of time for the sob oh why that is
weird why would you be doing something
anything there would be not supposed to
do that something went something went
all cerf insults a little stressful I
can't imagine what a 20/20 mode of this
I mean with time I'm gonna eventually
memorize the whole layout I'm gonna know
exactly where he's going each and every
time he wants to maneuver somewhere but
for now for now at least I'm learning a
few god damnit I did it again I was
talking on my own ass again pocket about
and around in near or on my own ass and
then I got caught with my ass hanging I
need to stop talking about my hand
systems they're gonna start as soon okay
alright alright alright alright let's
have them to see how many times I could
say alright and still not be funny so
what I've realized is cuz I'm an idiot
obviously they start from 9 and
obviously the only way they can go is 8
through the other ones so derp of course
they're coming that way
oh how how did you sneaks monk I get
talking and then you [ __ ] me Oh curse to
Mert Frick a Duke you damn it you suck
oh hi yeah okay alright fine
you still need one more piece and I
still need to punch you in the dick so
once we get our schedules lined up we'll
book you in for a nice dick punch about
that whoa what the [ __ ] he moved wait
did he
oh he didn't move I saw that god
I saw the blink Florrick I assume that
was a motion no it's 5:00 a.m. you're
not gonna stop me you might stop me
everyone might stop me that end of Dylan
might stop in nah hey it's hard to see
you in there but they know you're there
hey you don't do that don't do that yeah
you're getting too close to me stranger
danger in DD 6 a.m. already
I was longer do I gotta go I'm assuming
you a no we blinked I assumed is some ad
give me my goddamn time yet see in there
huh no not that shut it down
Frick was that the last piece oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] come on timer timer I don't know
why that was so stressful
I made it stressful for myself by
shouting and panicking
what do you have in store for us now oh
it's not Freddie it's the opposite of
Frodo so where are you gonna go straight
up maybe maybe straight to the ticket at
the tip top of it Tom / maybe maybe tip
top your top hat on top of Fred boy
they're kind of like passing on the
torch if you know what I mean nope not
up there so there's got to be something
else in this hellhole that I have known
well that's weird
that must mean that all bonds stir over
here must be to the left right that's
the only thing that can mean that I mean
a lot of things could mean that and I
can be stupid but you know I'm gonna
assume that I kind of halfway know what
I'm talking about and maybe this is
gonna leave me the woo
oh that's a guitar it's broken all the
tragedy
oh it's getting dark over here huh oh
I'll that's the sound that you can make
at this moment or you cannot make it
that's also an option oh it's the Bonnie
paper plate that appeared randomly in
five nights at Freddy's - shadow party
okay all right well someone has shed
their bowtie and pants so ah we seem to
be going in a circle
why oh hi you lost an ear and pants 0:06
the night you say oh I see how it is
well what's gonna happen in this one how
much more [ __ ] can you throw at me
I mean I can handle a lot of [ __ ] but
you know even an expert like myself has
to have days off No straight through the
night okay here we go I guess yeah
whatever who needs breaks breaks for the
week answer the damn call or booze
No thank you for working with me so much
this is the end go shift at the pub goes
pizzeria let me know your answer
ah sure why not yes
okay I'm gonna go with a big ole yes
good thing this job led to a survey
that's my favorite thing about this job
[ __ ] uh have they moved they maneuvered
they're already on their way
don't know how can I know I don't think
they're there
hey yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah i
Africa the guy what [ __ ] person how
fast was that I was not paying attention
I'm about to get it in my brain
I'm about to get bit in the brain there
Cobbs okay all right so that is night
five there's apparently one more
official night and yeah something was
going on with that call I just don't
know what someone was tapping on
something to get him to be done but I
just can't understand why I ball those
down over time for reporting that either
means someone's taking you away from the
place or something else is happening so
let me know what you think down the
comments below and as always in the next
video
[Music]